well I'm delighted to say I'm joined Now
by Neil deg Tyson Neil great to see you
thanks for here on your side of the pond
yes yes uh you've got another brilliant
book out Starry Messenger uh Cosmic
perspectives on civilization yeah as
always I have to ask you of the top just
released in paperback just just week ago
I think I talked to you when when the
hardback came out just in a nutshell for
those who haven't read this or any ofal
stuff what is the simple normal person's
version of what this is about things
look different from a cosmic perspective
and I think I I I quote Apollo 14
astronaut Edgar Mitchell in this book
and really the entire book is about that
quote May I if I may he says because by
the way when we went to the moon to
explore the moon we looked over our
shoulders and we discovered Earth for
the first time it was like a firmware
upgrade in our awareness of who we were
to each other to the planet and to
Nature that that's when the United
States founded the the Environmental
Protection Agency was 1970 while we were
on the moon the first Earth day was 1970
while we were on the moon and there's a
whole Litany of of of actions that
people took laws that were passed to
protect Earth here's what he noticed he
looked back and he
said you develop an instant Global
Consciousness a people orientation an
intense
dissatisfaction with the state of the
world and a compulsion to do something
about it from out there on the moon
International politics looks so petty
you want to grab a politician by the
Scruff of the neck and drag him a
quarter million miles out and say look
at that you son of a
can I say that absolutely this is
uncensored this is uncensored you just
did so so he was feeling the cosmic
perspective when you're that high up you
don't see the national borders you and
we're just one species down there on
this on this spaceship earth alone in
the darkness of the universe with no
hint that help will come from elsewhere
to save us from ourselves as Carl Sean
had poetically referenced and so you you
you're changed and so what I attempt in
this book is to take places where we
have arguments over holiday dinners when
the uncles and cousins and aunts come in
and say what would that look like from a
cosmic perspective and half of those
arguments evaporate in that instant
because like what are you fighting about
like really can't you see why we are
more the same than different you don't
see that because our tribal urges will
pick every little thing that you can
possibly say is different is your skin
differently reflective of sunlight than
mine well let's make a big deal of that
do you worship different gods or no gods
or any let's make a big deal of that oh
you sleep with this person in this
instead of that person of our own
species let's make a big deal of that
why are we so flawed human beings I
think that feature mattered to our
survival 100,000 years ago 50,000 years
ago because you don't know if another
group that showed up on the horizon will
they harm you take your resources or not
you don't know that but you do know that
other people in your tribe they smell
like you they kind of look like you and
it's easy to distinguish them from the
others so that may have had survival
value 50 100,000 today when we have
civilization and society and our
intellect to know and understand our DNA
it's it's quite I don't want to call it
childish well yeah okay I'm going to say
it that it this tribalism in the world
feels childish to me it's what what
would an alien say they come say oh
you're all the same species you say yeah
yeah okay uh and you're fighting for
these reasons but you're the same
species right what are you what are you
doing why and then they'll run home and
Report there's no sign of intelligent
life on
Earth just saying I did the last like I
mentioned to you before in a previous
interview I did the last television
interview with Professor Steven Hawking
and it was a fascinating insight into
that remarkable brain that he had but
one question really stuck with me and
one answered it I said to him what is in
your estimation the biggest threat to
mankind and he said when artificial
intelligence learns to self-design and
other people have extrapolated that to
mean look the thing is when I AI gets
really Advanced and gets potentially
sened it will look at human beings and
think well this lot are a complete waste
of time right why on what's the point of
them right for the reasons that you've
just brilliantly outlined and they'll
just basically kill us all and and make
a world for themselves yes right it
doesn't involve the human frailties well
just consider that right now AI is
basically everywhere there's no tech
company that isn't fully exploiting the
value of AI to their business model in
my field which is not even a corporate
entity it's just science in my field
astrophysics we've been using AI at any
possible point that it could Advance us
we use it and we've been using it for
decades why aren't you terrified of it
because you're very positive about AI I
I let me okay there are people who will
read you the riot act about the future
of AI and many of them are deep in the
field so I'm not here to undo their
concerns all I would tell you is AI in
its sort of restricted form where I have
a task I don't want to do it let a
machine do it and let's teach it and
have it machine learn what it is I need
it to do and have it do it that's kind
of how AI has manifested in society why
do you not fear that AI can become
genuinely sentient and start making
decisions completely on its own yeah
depend you can make a decision but how
much power are you going to Grant it all
right if we I mean look I don't want to
put words in your mouth here and I
certainly don't compare my brain to
yours however my my simple mind my
simple mind says to me that as with the
internet as with all great new
Innovations but particularly with AI
given its enormous power I can
absolutely see all the positives
especially in science in medicine all
these things and there's an existential
risk on the other side of that yes well
because inevitably people with nefarious
motives will get their hands on it and
they will want AI to perform in a
negative destructive manner because that
is the nature of the Beast it's why when
Lance Armstrong was the best cyclist in
the world he doped to get an even bigger
Advantage so they all followed him and
they all started doping and it ruined
cycling it's it's the nature of the
Beast that humans with our brains will
take some people with really dark
aspirations for this new Wonder thing
will take it and miss use it how how are
you not as scared as I'm about that yeah
so I think any technological Advance has
always had a dark side in the hands of
Nefarious actors so I don't yes AI poses
an existential risk so too did nuclear
weapons right so so too do weapons in
general all right and so uh I was on a
on a on a um on a a board that served
the Pentagon uh at a defense Innovation
board it was and we confronted this
issue with AI in the military and we
arrived at a the conclusion that if a
kill decision has to be made a human
being needs to be in that Loop you
cannot have ai make that decision
without a human being participating in
it recognizing that AI is inevitable in
the in the in that world and so but you
want to put in some constraints and yes
this is not the Rogue actor right these
are rational people making these
decisions so yes we should be concerned
I agree I agree but does that mean you
want to shut down all of AI I don't
think that's no I don't mean that but do
do you think with your brilliant mind do
you not think that AI can ever
self-design uh yeah I mean that's the
crucial question yeah I mean at there
different levels of this I was quite
impressed the day I learned that I could
take software tell it what I want wanted
it to do and it completely wrote my
computer program for me and it was a
Flawless program I said oh that's good
yeah but is that based on the fact that
he got access to everything you've ever
written no no because I told it what I
needed it to do and it just wrote the
code but that's but that's different
that's obeying instructions and giving
you a brilliant version of that
incredibly quickly and I'll give you one
example so a friend of my eldest son uh
his mother was very upset that he hadn't
thanked her for a 30th dinner party she
threw for him for his 30th birthday and
So eventually he just went on to GP chat
he said give me a not I can send my
mother right and he sent it to his
mother this like screen long thing and
she rang him sobbing in tears and said
you've never ever moved me the way you
did with this and he hasn't had the
heart to tell her that it was G it was
secret is busted now it was it was this
chat thing right so so that's the
problem right how could you say he
hasn't had the heart to tell you're this
is my International broadcast and you're
okay I haven't named the people
concerned for obvious reasons but you
get my point right yeah so um that's I
think a I would count that as nefarious
it's like it's emotion that he didn't
really think or feel um but consider
that when when chat GPT arrived and you
realize it could compose your term paper
people poop their pants okay people but
well liberal arts folks poop their pants
because they realized oh my gosh I've
been creating all this stuff and now a
machine could do it in seconds and then
I thought well suppose I were in their
shoes because I was as a scientist and I
saw the computer power encroach into the
world I said pick something you can give
it to do that you didn't want to do
anyway like right instruction manuals or
tour guides or there's plenty of stuff
to give AI to do reserving your own
creativity for yourself plus I learned
in one of them where they scanned these
books what was it 100 something thousand
books 15 of my books were in that data
set I learned I'm not in the the lawsuit
okay I want just want to see how it
unfolds but I'm intrigued by that
because it means if you ask it questions
some fraction of what it finds to be
true or interesting or responsive will
be drawn from my content which are
non-fiction books about the universe
presumably it will be including this
book by the way right and it'll be able
to write speeches based on everything
you've written right yes you could do a
lecture you could say give me a 3,000
thousand word lecture based on what I've
written about X but you know what it's
not going to do it's not well not
yet is it going to invent something new
well that's the question well that's my
point that that's my point if you if you
that's what I mean by self-design yeah
well no okay isn't that what it means
suppose you're a naturalist and you on
the seashore and you find a new shell
that is not yet cataloged and you call a
friend of yours I found this new shell
you don't put it on the internet you
just have a new shell and it devel a
whole new understanding of by valves if
that's not on the internet your AI will
be clueless about it he'll have no idea
cuz the AI is not wandering the
seashores looking for new science but
you're assuming at the moment that AI is
still under our control it kind of is
well it's limited to anything that's on
the internet because it can't think for
itself outside the internet right but I
can think outside the internet the key
question which Step Hawking was Raising
was he believed there would be a time
when it could literally think for itself
and at that moment it would calculate
when it reached that point the humans
were redundant there were points right
so that's a different issue from whether
it can invent new knowledge and and to
me well I don't see why coming to it as
a scientist we are on the frontier
looking where no one has looked before
inventing methods of detection that
where no one has detected before right
an AI in a box is not doing that until
we offered that information right and so
in my field there dreams of data that we
don't have the time or the bandwidth to
analyze we train AI on it and it helps
us figure out what the universe is like
but we are the ones who got the data for
it not it so for me that's a fundamental
limit to how creative AI can possibly be
ever well yeah I'm going to say ever
because the AI is not walking the beach
but my brain is telling me it is
inevitable that at some stage hopefully
not in my lifetime cuz I want to here AI
will be able to do stuff completely on
its own originate original thought and
it's at that point make the kill
decision on its own yes and it's at that
point stepen Hawkings says we're done
but you don't think it's going to happen
well I'd like to have more confidence in
the capacity of our species to make the
right decisions really than that we make
so many terrible decision we do we do
look at the state of the world we do
it's bad awful people doing awful things
it's everywhere you know I I me and my
people we tend to the universe and the
universe is in good shape I would say is
it you all are messing up Earth go back
go back and fix Earth just blame me
you're a human being as well but I I
have a just an allegory about the robot
wielding a gun uh I forgive me for not
remembering the name of this person who
uttered this but upon realizing that
with the power of a bow and arrow you
could kill another human being without
actually looking them in the eyes M and
the conclusion was that's the end of
bravery and so I thought about this whoa
any tool where you can kill at a
distance that's cowardly on some level
and the the the pro progress of military
conflict has been how far away can you
kill at a distance you know have unmaned
drones K or or missiles that's
intercontinental ballistic missile let
me kill a whole city and not even within
5,000 miles of the city so the fact that
a robot is wielding a gun is that any
different from a guided missile I don't
think so but the danger comes if the
robot with the gun can think for itself
and not take instructions from a human
yeah you're couching all your defense of
why I I shouldn't be worried with I
don't think we're going to reach a point
where where a robot can make that
decision you know what it is we don't
really fully understand human
consciousness so to suggest that a robot
will achieve Consciousness and then make
moral decisions that weren't otherwise
pre-programmed in that's I don't know
how far in the future that is but I
think we have to understand our own mind
first which we don't not at the level we
would need to to speak with that level
right what what scares you most about
civilization the future the world the
universe oh that's a great question
thank you uh I I would
say we are losing our capacity to
distinguish what is true from what is
not what is objectively true and the
methods and tools of science are
exquisitly designed to establish what is
objectively true and objective truth is
I perform an experiment I get a result
other people perform other experiments
get the same result it repeats there it
is how damaging was the covid pandemic
to trust in scientists because it
obviously followed exactly the path
you've just said whereas new information
came out and got tested different
scientists would reach different
conclusions then there would be more
consensus but the public are watching
all this and they're thinking well how
can we trust the science yeah so some of
this is because we as a species have are
very poor understanding of probability
and statistics in fact there's an entire
chapter in here called uh what do I call
risk and reward about we you can read
you can look at a bar chart and it tells
you that you should do this
but someone comes up to you and says no
don't do that look this would happen to
me I will never do that this one person
out of thousands that might have filled
this bar chart will convince you to not
follow the bar chart because the bar
chart doesn't have a face saying do this
it's better for you the eyewitness
testimony of the individual emotionally
overrides actual data and this is
replete across the internet a person
what you what's irresistible clickbait
someone on YouTube saying the
establishment wants you to think this
but I've got the answer that they don't
want you to know clickbait right there
if we had better tools if from the
educational system how to deal with
information data knowledge statistics I
think we would be dare I say inoculated
against the charlott how much of an
enemy to science and the Integrity of
science is social Med media in
amplifying the conspiracy theor yeah I
don't want to blame social media I it's
too easy to blame social media and I
want to blame social media but I don't I
don't isn't it a major part of it
because it magnifies it's it's a
magnifier massively fuels the conspiracy
fuel it throws fuel on something that I
think was already would we ever have had
a vaccine that was accepted there in
social media era I'm not sure because
you just see that there are yeah if Co
were 50% lethal yeah yeah yes was it was
low single digits so that's low enough
so people can think that they're not in
that low single digits and everyone who
died from not being vaccinated is not
writing a book that's antivaccine
because they're dead Okay so dead people
don't talk so so there's a one-sided a
awareness of the value of these advances
in medical science so what what I'm as
an educator I don't like coming after
the fact and hitting people on the head
I I would ask the educational system you
need to improve people's understanding
of what science is and how and why it
works and the communication I think
could have been a little more respectful
of the statistics involved here's how
the now in this is in hindsight granted
who's thinking this at the time in
hindsight I would say the CDC or
whatever agency it is should come out
and say as of this week here is what the
science tells us this the the vaccine is
90% effective at this it prevents you
from going to the hospital Hospital
it'll prevent you from dying in this
percentage of cases then there are these
adverse effects in this percent of
cases um and wear mask or don't wear
mask the data says maybe you should do
this clean the clean the packages we all
clean the food because they thought it
was primarily respiratory rather than
also um in your blood okay so the next
week more data come in we've adjusted
these numbers now if the public were
experienced at interpreting changes in
statistical information then you could
trust that everybody would make the
right decision in the interest of Public
Health but we don't have that background
the the the people delivering
information I think didn't trust that we
would think about the statistics
properly and it became this Mosh Pit
when you look at the
universe every day every day quite
difficult to look at you sp a lot of
time immersed obviously we know so much
more than we used to what what are the
unanswered aspects of it all that you
would absolutely abolutely love to cry
yeah I so I've lived long enough that I
no
longer put so much emotion in the
unanswered question of the day because I
know it will ultimately be answered I
remembered 20 years ago see we need need
to know how old the universe is it was
uncertain by a factor of two for most of
my time in graduate school and now it
we've got it tight so that's no longer
an interesting question so for me the
most interesting question is are we
smart enough as a
species to answer the questions we've
posed or perhaps even more than that are
we smart enough to even know what
questions to ask in the first place
that's a question about human physiology
for me Elon Musk is of a view that we
need to have our life taken to other
planets uh and he also says that we are
in desperate need of more people not
fewer people on the planet what do you
think of those two things as a matter
can we sustain a population with the
resources we have and our access to it
uh there some projections show that
we'll level off at about 10 billion
people on Earth and I find those
projections convincing unless we double
our life expectancy if we do and we run
out of space we need another planet so I
kind of like other planets cuz I'm an
astrophysicist where would you most like
to live there's no choice in the matter
it would have to be Mars there's no
other own ship no no could there ever be
you'd have to well you'd have to go to
Venus and try to have it not be 900
Degrees fhe okay that's and I did the
calculation you can cook a 16in pizza on
the window sill in 3 seconds okay you
would vaporize too but you it's a fast
it's a in the atmosphere so no you don't
Mars is has a 24-hour day approximately
it's tipped on its axis it has polar ice
caps as we still do for now on Earth it
goes through Seasons uh we think there's
a reservoir of water that was once there
on the surface now Frozen as a
permafrost so if there's any planet that
is terraformable it would be Mars as a
as a as another home for folks on Earth
the reason to do it is not to protect
our species in case an asteroid comes
and hits our Earth that's the wrong fine
it makes a headline but think about it
if you have the resources to terraform
Mars and ship a billion people there you
have the resources to deflect an
asteroid from Earth okay this this is
not what what are by the way you
mentioned as what is the chance of an
asteroid smacking into us the good thing
about like the movies the good thing
about this is that the bigger the bad
the
asteroid the farther away we will likely
Discover it before it does any damage
but isn't it the less likely that we can
protect ourselves the bigger it is I
no well if we discover an asteroid that
might hit us in 150 years plenty of time
to do something about it given the rate
of technology and the Ingenuity have a
gigantic existential asid it's not a
Bruce Willis bomb thing so what do you
do yeah you go in and you you deflect it
how oh by any shove on it that's
sideways oh you're president of the
United States well yeah there's a
massive asteroid it's going to crash
into the
world kind we saw the bru will is moving
we have engineering plans for deflecting
asteroids and there are multiple ways to
do it you can put a little you can have
a gravitational tug where you can have a
spacecraft that sits just ahead of it
and the two of them will want to drift
towards one another but you take the
spacecraft and put little retro rocket
and it'll keep T and if you get this
early enough 1 cmet per second it the
tiniest amount will accumulate over time
and you just have to make it so that it
overshoots Earth or unders shoots Earth
compared to the original path well
because you know the dinosaurs would
still be here if they had NASA if they
had NASA yeah just saying so what is the
thing that keeps you up at night what's
the thing you're most scared about
whether we are wise enough to be
Shepherds of our own Technologies and is
that does that come back to the cosmic
perspective of us actually recognizing
how lucky we are yes you have to making
decisions according where does the
wisdom come from it's not from the
Internet it's not from from fighting in
trenches it's stepping back and say oh
my gosh life is precious our species is
precious Earth is precious Earth
sustains us with its Animal Kingdom and
plant kingdom and its atmosphere and its
oceans the holistic picture that that is
if we don't have the wisdom to
understand that and make sure that it
sustains us we don't deserve this planet
you know why I've never said that before
that's mean I like it no that's no I no
you're right let me cast that a positive
to the extent that we can develop wisdom
to become better Shepherds of our world
and our place in it uh we will be
deserving of an indefinite unlimited
future I preferred your first V tough
love it's tough
love finally where can I get one of your
ties it's fantastic no robots ever going
to choose one this by this has all the
plants except for Pluto really why have
you left Pluto out don't get me started
well what's the short
I see Pluto's here but it's it's in it's
in the yeah yeah Pluto get over it Pluto
had it coming just letting you know it's
brilliant to see you I I love catching
up with you well thank you because all
the things are really genuinely
concerning me I can just ask somebody
who knows well yeah happy to offer some
I'm glad you're positive about AI
because I'm I want to be but I'm always
mindful of what Stephen Hawking said to
me and that that makes me just don't
throw out the baby with the bath water
it'll and AI can help us design new
drugs drugs uh new diseases there's so
much it can do yet people spooked by
chat GPT want to throw you me say design
new cures for diseases did I what say
you said design new diseases I did not
mean to say which is exactly what I'm
worried about that's what I'm worried
about Neil degrass Tyson uh your book
Starry Messenger Cosmic perspectives on
civilization as long as he manages to
say the
right it's a great book good to see you
all right thanks sir all the
best